starwars the last Jedi somehow managed
to keep pre-release detail shrouded in
secrecy and that caused fans to dream up
their own unusual theories and
speculations before even buying a ticket
considering that at 2 and 1/2 hours the
last Jedi is the longest franchise entry
to date there's a lot to look forward to
that no amount of teasers could possibly
spoil but some of the behind-the-scenes
details surrounding the movie were
guarded a little less carefully from
easter-egg reveals to production
conflicts as well as even one or two
plot related scoops that came through a
little earlier than expected here's what
you might not know about episode 8 one
last stand due to the unexpected passing
of actress Carrie Fisher Princess Leia's
planned appearance in episode 9 became a
point of major speculation for fans
given that her part in the next film was
supposed to be enhanced the loss made
some fans wonder whether the filmmakers
might digitally insert her into episode
9 like they had in rogue one
Lucasfilm boss Kathleen Kennedy however
dispelled rumors of a potential CGI laya
appearance in episode 9 and said that
the last Jedi will mark Princess Leia's
last physical appearance in the Star
Wars universe perhaps it's a fitting
final stand for Fisher because as
director Rian Johnson has since revealed
she was instrumental in his script
writing process for the picture Johnson
said that while developing episode 8
he'd go to her house and talk with her
about the script what resulted were a
kind of stream of consciousness jazz
poetry sessions and that their
conversations usually led to changes in
the script such as in the dialogue
considering a large portion of Fischer's
non Star Wars career was spent doctoring
screenplays like this the last Jedi
sounds like it'll feature a culmination
of her many talents actor objections
it's no secret that Mark Hamill hasn't
been entirely pleased with the process
of bringing Star Wars back for the new
trilogy first he was disappointed over
his lack of screen time in the force
awakens and its treatment of han Solo
and now he's taken umbrage with Rian
Johnson's vision for the last Jedi in an
interview with Vanity Fair Hamill said
that he confronted Johnson about his
thoughts on the script and told him I
pretty much fundamentally disagree with
every choice you've made for this
character
luckily for Johnson though Hamill wasn't
put off enough to walk away and instead
he told the writer director having said
that I have
gotten it off my chest and my job now is
to take what you've created and do my
best to realize your vision so even
though the last Jedi will feature a Luke
Skywalker that Luke Skywalker himself
doesn't approve of at least the actor
will be giving at his best effort
unique influences even if Mark Hamill
doesn't quite get his vision Rian
Johnson sure posts some novel sources of
inspiration for his segment of Star Wars
films for example the aerial dogfights
and space combat scene in the last Jedi
were at least partially inspired by 1949
12 o'clock high an American war drama
about the US Air Force's involvement in
World War two additionally 1964 s3
outlaw Samurai has impacted his
directing style meaning that that
movie's pulpy plot and hack and slash
sword fighting action will have a
presence among space drama and fancy
light sabers of Star Wars the film
series drawing influence from classic
films is nothing new since the New Hope
borrowed from 1954 is the dam Busters
and Akira Kurosawa's 1958 film the
hidden fortress so while those might not
be the most ordinary Muse movies maybe
this means an even truer return to
classic Star Wars Royal cameo if you
were tickled by the news that James Bond
actor Daniel Craig at a cameo in the
force awakens well you're in for a royal
surprise in the last Jedi there's loads
of room as men but you know he's a hot
secret to keep by me in the in the Star
Wars universe I'm sure they wouldn't be
able to keep that secret
I know nothing Princess Harry and
William were both seen on set goofing
around and actor John boyega confirmed
that Tom Hardy was there as well boyega
said of the surprise guests they were
there I'm sick of hiding it I think it
was leaked anyway there were images he
took it a step further in November 2017
by telling The Hollywood Reporter that
not only would both Prince's appear as
stormtroopers in the film in addition to
Hardy and singer Gary Barlow but they'd
all donned the instantly recognizable
armor for the same scene scar switcheroo
when it came to kylo ren's gnarly facial
scar Rian Johnson has admitted that he
moved it simply because it didn't look
right back in the force awakens now it
resides in kylos right cheek rather than
the bridge of his nose
not because of midi-chlorians but just
because of his own personal preference
it's not exactly universe shattering
cannon reconfiguration there but it's
something kylo Ren fans will certainly
take notice of code name just as Return
of the Jedi used the fake working title
blue harvest to fool autographs seeking
fans during filming the last Jedi had
its own pretend moniker in play while
cameras were still rolling on the film
but instead of holding any clues to the
substance of Episode eight the fake name
was simply space bear yep space bear
that might be some subtle nod to
Chewbacca or one of the other furry
creatures coming along in the last Jedi
or the fact that pores are basically the
new a walks or it might just be Rian
Johnson toying with everyone because he
can thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check all the school stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]